Trascrizione:
All'inizio,
io i libri li odiavo.
A dire la verità, da bambina
mi portavano via
tutte le donne della mia vita:
mia mamma, mia nonna, mia zia.
A un certo punto, loro aprivano i libri
ed erano assenti, erano come stregate.
Io non ero più interessante:
mi dicevano, adesso tu disegna,
stai un po' tranquilla
che io devo leggere.
E naturalmente, per me,
questi libri erano dei nemici.
Quindi, quando ho imparato l'alfabeto,
ho pensato di capire cos'era
quella specie di prodigio
che addirittura li faceva diventare,
i libri, più importanti di me.
E però sono rimasta
praticamente subito fregata,
perché mi ricordo bene
il giorno in cui ho imparato
a memoria, per la scuola,
"Novembre" di Giovanni Pascoli,
e la stavo imparando davanti a un orto,
tutto secco, tutto stecchito.
E man mano che io dicevo
le parole di quella poesia,
la realtà iniziava come
a illuminarsi, come a rivelarsi,
perché quelle parole,
quelle parole poetiche, letterarie,
avevano un potere enorme.
E allora sono rimasta subito fregata.
E poi, quando sono diventata adolescente,
i libri mi hanno dato il colpo di grazia,
perché naturalmente, subito,
anche se i social ancora non esistevano
quando io avevo 12, 13, 14 anni,
però comunque vivevo in questa società,
e questa è una società
che dall'inizio ti dice
che tu devi vincere,
che nella vita, assolutamente,
tu devi essere,
o almeno sembrare perfetta.
Quindi io ricordo bene
l'ansia di prepararmi,
di truccarmi, di mascherarmi
per andare in corso il sabato pomeriggio
e riuscire a sostenere
lo sguardo degli altri.
E naturalmente era tutta una società
piena di aspettative,
che si aspettava che io entrassi
in determinati canoni,
che fossi bella in un certo modo
e parlassi in un certo modo,
e che la mia famiglia
fosse in un certo modo.
Io, naturalmente, ero un'insicura cronica,
e non ero affatto come mi dicevano
che dovevo essere.
Allora io cosa facevo?
Io aprivo un libro, e lì c'era un casino.
C'erano famiglie infelici,
c'erano persone piene di problemi,
c'erano contraddizioni,
vuoti, fallimenti, paure, perdite,
e allora io stavo bene.
Perché finalmente, dicevo,
io ho trovato qualcuno
che è come me e che mi sta dicendo
che anche se io sono sbagliata
in realtà vado bene così,
con tutti i miei sbagli.
E quindi, già dal liceo,
io ho imparato e ho capito
che la lettura serviva proprio a me,
per vivere e soprattutto per disubbidire,
perché se là fuori tutti mi dicevano
che io dovevo sembrare, essere
perfetta, vincente, brava, bella,
la letteratura è piena di gente
assolutamente non raccomandabile.
Se voi aprite un romanzo bello,
cioè un classico,
un romanzo che ha tenuto nel tempo,
voi ci trovate assassini,
adultere, orfani,
tutte persone poco raccomandabili;
e quelle persone poco raccomandabili
diventavano miei amici.
Anche perché la bellezza
di aprire un romanzo
è che tu non li vedi, i personaggi.
Tu non li può giudicare
dal loro aspetto esteriore:
tu entri dentro, e ascolti la loro anima.
E allora io ho iniziato a capire
che le persone mi si rivelavano
non quando apparivano,
ma quando mi parlavano,
perché noi non siamo delle immagini, no?
Noi non siamo delle definizioni:
noi siamo delle storie.
E quando io sono diventata adulta,
è successa questa cosa.
Perché ero sempre insicura: un po' meno,
ma abbastanza insicura,
come da adolescente,
ma nel frattempo era successo qualcosa
di ancora più complicato, nel mondo,
e cioè erano arrivati i social.
E io mi sono ritrovata
improvvisamente circondata
da fotografie di persone
sempre felici, sempre belle,
dove si festeggiava soltanto:
solo nascite, solo promozioni
sul lavoro, solo feste.
E io dicevo, cosa è successo all'umanità,
visto che, da lettrice, ero così abituata
a stare dentro i problemi.
E io stessa, nella mia vita,
avevo un sacco di problemi.
E l'arrivo dei social mi ha mandata
terribilmente in crisi.
Io aprivo "Madame Bovary", per esempio,
e mi sentivo come lei,
una ragazza di provincia
che legge perché quella vita non le basta,
e perché si legge contro,
come dice anche Daniel Pennac,
si legge per ribellarsi
a una vita soltanto, che ti sta stretta.
E però io ero circondata da vite perfette.
Quindi ho detto:
questi social io li devo capire,
però li devo capire come? Leggendo.
Quando sono arrivati i social,
è sembrato
che la letteratura non valesse più,
perché cosa te ne fai
di leggere le storie immaginarie
di persone che non esistono,
quando puoi spiare persone che conosci?
Il problema è, sempre: tu cosa spii?
Spii delle foto, spii dei momenti,
spii dei selfie, spii dei sorrisi,
spii determinate luci.
Ma cosa c'è dietro quelle foto,
cosa c'è tra una foto e l'altra?
Quali sono tutti i giorni,
i giorni in cui le cose non vanno,
il giorno in cui ti si chiede di cambiare,
cosa c'è dentro quel corpo?
Cosa c'è dietro i trabocchetti
dei vestiti, cosa c'è?
E allora io ho recuperato Raskolnikov
di Dostoevskij, l'assassino,
ho recuperato tutte le donne,
le madri imperfette di Elsa Morante,
ho recuperato tutti quei personaggi
che sono sempre stati i miei amici,
i miei amici immaginari,
e che però erano gli altri, i diversi,
quelli che non andavano bene.
Eppure sono loro,
che mi hanno sempre salvata.
Noi viviamo in una società
in cui gli algoritmi dentro i social
ci fanno conoscere le persone
che la pensano come noi,
che abitano vicino a noi.
Noi veniamo al mondo
e siamo dentro una famiglia,
siamo dentro un quartiere,
siamo dentro un'educazione,
una storia degli altri.
Ma il punto è che noi,
come prima missione,
dobbiamo diventare noi stessi.
E per diventare noi stessi
e capire chi siamo,
anche se i nostri genitori
si aspettano delle cose diverse.
Anche se la società si aspetta
delle cose diverse da noi,
noi però dobbiamo tradire
queste aspettative.
Ma come facciamo a farlo,
se non ci specchiamo dentro la storia
di un altro, di un diverso,
di una persona che abita
dall'altra parte del mondo,
che viene da una storia
completamente diversa,
che ci prende e ci porta via
come fanno gli amici,
perché è questo che fanno i romanzi,
ti prendono e ti portano via
e ti fanno capire
che quel posto dove sei nata,
che quella scuola dove sei andata,
o quella scuola a cui non ti sei iscritta
non è un destino:
noi siamo liberi di scegliere.
Il problema è che non
impariamo a scegliere
se non immaginiamo
le vite diverse che possiamo vivere,
e non possiamo immaginare queste vite
se non ci entriamo dentro.
Io apro un libro
e ascolto i sentimenti, i segreti,
i pensieri di quel personaggio,
cioè io divento lui.
Questo non è possibile
facendo nient'altro che non sia leggere.
E se io, però, divento lui,
io capisco la mia vita.
Se io imparo le parole
che ha lui per raccontarsi,
io imparo a raccontare la mia.
Io lo so che viviamo in un mondo
che dà un sacco di importanza al corpo,
Però la nostra storia,
che c'è dentro, non si vede.
E allora abbiamo bisogno
delle parole per raccontarci:
e soprattutto, sapete perché?
Perché per raccontarci
dobbiamo accettarci,
dobbiamo perdonarci.
Quando noi apriamo un romanzo,
sentiamo un personaggio
che sta raccontando
tutto ciò che non direbbe
mai ad alta voce,
che non pubblicherebbe mai
da nessuna parte.
E noi impariamo a capirlo,
noi proviamo dell'affetto,
proviamo della solidarietà,
perché tu non puoi provare solidarietà
per un'immagine perfetta,
tu puoi provare solidarietà per una storia
piena di sacrifici, piena di fallimenti.
Un romanzo, per cominciare,
ha bisogno di un vuoto, una mancanza.
Nessuna storia inizia se non si reagisce.
Eppure una perdita,
un fallimento, un vuoto,
sono tutto ciò di cui ci dicono
che ci dobbiamo vergognare.
Ma non è così.
Noi non cambiamo senza un dolore,
noi non cresciamo.
La vita, scrive Roth, significa sbagliare,
se no siamo perfetti,
siamo morti o siamo finti.
Allora cos'è che
mi ha insegnato la letteratura?
Mi ha insegnato due cose:
a perdonarmi tutti
gli errori che ho fatto,
tutti i problemi che non aggiusterò,
a benedirli.
E mi ha insegnato, anche,
ad amare e a perdonare
tutta l'imperfezione
delle persone che ho accanto.
Mi ha insegnato a trovare solidarietà
per le persone più lontane,
come persone che vengono
da un altro mondo,
che si mettono in barca,
che cercano di raggiungere
un paese migliore,
per le persone che io non conosco,
e che stanno in delle periferie
con delle storie piene di problemi,
perché sicuramente leggere non è comodo.
Sicuramente leggere è pericoloso.
Perché se stiamo ognuno
nella sua piccola caverna,
ognuno nel suo mondo,
e non ci mettiamo dentro delle storie
di abbandono, di forte emarginazione,
allora noi forse stiamo meglio,
però siamo anche in prigione,
perché nessuno di noi può stare bene
dentro una vita soltanto.
Noi, per essere felici,
abbiamo bisogno non solo di accettarci
e di diventare chi davvero siamo,
abbiamo bisogno di farlo degli altri.
La nostra felicità
è la felicità degli altri.
Allora, se leggiamo un libro
che ci racconta il dramma
di una persona che sta migrando,
che sta cercando un riscatto,
il dramma di una persona
lasciata sola, non capita,
che si sente diversa
e cerca di comunicarlo,
e ci mettiamo nei suoi panni,
noi, quando un giorno andremo a votare,
quando un giorno incontreremo
quella persona per strada,
non potremo girarci dall'altra parte,
perché la conosciamo.
Non la giudichiamo, non ne abbiamo paura:
la conosciamo, gli vogliamo bene.
Questo è il cemento possibile
di una società migliore.
Lasciatemela, questa utopia,
ma io ci credo da morire
che se tu leggi, apri un libro,
tu inizi a provare solidarietà
per tutti i diversi, per tutti gli altri.
E se tu ti specchi negli altri,
tu trovi te stesso.
E se tu ti eserciti a essere,
anziché dannarti per sembrare,
abiti questo mondo,
lo abiti non dentro una vita soltanto.